are you guys going that far oh my god
run oh I'll get a shot where did that
come from
oh these right here Griffin I'm coming
down it's not over start over
nobody give me Griffin Griffin crawl to
me get down here get over here Peaks
take about I'm coming no cable - I'm
saying Pikachu there he is
I can't wait ready everybody ready yeah
what how does my guys here look like a
dandelion I don't like that oh we want
three you want to edit you can Scott
yeah my character looks stupid okay
girlfriend's gonna edit his character
hold on
alright hold on we gotta go to three-man
squad anyway yeah don't worry about it
you look great oh my god
this is already like your hair looks
really awesome it's like kind of I want
a hat on a brillo y'all like brillo hair
[Music]
all right well whoever's in the chat
welcome there's only a couple of us for
the moment coke might be getting on in a
minute
Stevie and Frank will not be here and
pretty soon we'll have a new layout
sadly we don't tonight
I blame Arthur thirteen people what's up
if you guys got any questions st. in
chat and I'll read it out to Griffin in
huh okay oh my god let me just look let
me just turn on this [ __ ] on my own I
want to hear I don't want to hear your
nonsense I'm not gonna read some bad
that's exactly what you do that's your
move exactly no it's not
I never said that when what's up Mighty
Max you know I always taken forever here
we go all right finally Jebus get ready
to watch the worst player in the worst
fire team this is gonna be the worst
cheese
anybody watch the staircase know what no
crash yes yeah applix did you guys see
Incredibles no I know you saw you were
like she's oh yeah yeah yeah Pikachu is
a super excited about last night was
telling us all no do you like love that
watches that together bobble
I'll let me turn this off okay how come
you're not showing oh it does sound good
whatever anything on my yeah nobody
wants to see that [ __ ]
plus I don't want my camera hooked up
because I've been doing the elgato thing
so I had to okay I'm looking at the chat
- all right all right let's do it let's
do it go
like that's gonna mansion huh but I'm
gonna pay wall man you put it can you
put a mark down so we know what the hell
we're doing yeah give me a second
mansions about here yet disaster capital
market ready disaster I already did it
all right what do you try to wake the
Griffon all the controls are on the
screen now so you should be great
wait is it oh yeah when you drop you'll
see you like how to crouch change
weapons
oh that wonder people there's they they
optimize a little are we eject dropping
dropping dropping dropping nothing okay
oh [ __ ] wait wait wait wait
well we would look we should be headed
towards that blue mark right yeah yeah
right down it's almost straight down oh
I feel like we're gonna get hit no it's
not almost straight down Craig don't
tell Griffin that he's gonna fall behind
I see I sorta see Craig and all man I'm
nowhere near you guys yeah oh my god I'm
like the only one still in it I'm so far
away I'm gonna spill area cuz I got a
feeling there's gonna be 8,000 people
there whatever it's not even loaded in
so I'll just come to you well it doesn't
even matter cuz they can't even see my
thing yeah I see like two or three dudes
Peaks there's guys to your right yeah
well [ __ ] that mansion oh okay the thing
is there I see it now or you can run our
be free like what does free lock means
so you hold RB and then you move your
right analog stick so you can look
behind you and still run straight oh
yeah
Oh Oh doh yeah yeah I think I should be
streaming since we're not doing is
you're not gonna give me this this is
dumb to not have my video
yeah I agree but if we do that we're
taking the people away from ours our
chair Mille [ __ ] our channel oh yeah
what are you talking about our channels
we swear to God with the two of you I
swear to God how much okay I need a gun
fast I gotta make a oops we're not in
the zone the zone is that military base
just be aware of our surroundings
there's people coming from an army
Pikachu oh cool wait how do I wait wait
oh my god what just happen how do I get
the gun I thought I picked up a gun but
I didn't you didn't go like one upstairs
there's one upstairs Jesus Christ this
is already a nightmare oh I see a gun
here we go I'm gonna go down to the Red
House and check them out how do you load
[ __ ] again I'll hold eggs cold hold X to
reload well I don't have any bullets for
this well-well come with us come on ask
our house where the guns will take you
to the house of the guns how do you get
rid of the gun hey come here girlfriend
there's a [ __ ] ton of guns over here
there's also a jacket in here oh I'm
sixteen
I'm sixteen here Griffin yeah give it a
griffon yeah I'm not gonna Griffin if he
[ __ ] like guys over here just game
enough well we're good Griffin right
here a bathroom right here can you get
out of the way I'm out of there go get
it there's also a look there's a vest
right here right outside the bathroom
well honey that's not picking up the
ammo oh my god you got a look at it it
says right in front of me okay there we
go the chat is laughing at us
hey guys any backpacks I need some
[ __ ] I can't I don't have a backpack
well if you guys come into this room
over here there's um there's guns okay
wait how do you make it fully automatic
again how do you do that
laughs deep a starlet firing that lefty
okay there you go burst single burst oh
this is a [ __ ] gun oh no no it's not
at was t is not yeah so there's some
bandages here picks them up Griffin hold
up hold up I actually don't means this
so don't leave this pistol wait what is
happening I keep dropping alright we got
it on his own soon all right ready
yeah do we sit car anyone to the dome
did you mop it now you want to look for
a car wait who's this oh we're not that
bad that's more I don't put a I'm gonna
put a marker here all right let's go you
want to start running that way well we
gotta go we have no backpacks and all
right how brilliant right there's unless
good friend come join the other year
Pikachu come join us
yeah you don't know where you are god
this is a nightmare
we got 22 people watching nice what he
cares come on let's get to the zone
Pikachu have our back skirting around
I'm right am i going towards the blue
thing right yes yes yes yes harder
all right next to Griffin so he dies you
know you should be protecting him you're
supposed to use bodyguard pay you
talking about I thought you pay Pikachu
to be your in-game bodyguard was I wrong
about that funny remotely I know
Pikachu's expendable Oh you should take
a bull
now this isn't my first time playing
Club G but it might as well be with
these clowns first time it feels like
it's your first time every time
there's probably gonna be some people in
that guy it really does but we should we
should we should check this outside and
not another one
oh I hear a car yeah you do
oh you silly run it's all fair okay
don't shoot guys don't waste bullets
there's another car over there okay
let's go I'm gonna shoot I don't know if
they try to hit us they try to hit you
guys yeah oh [ __ ]
also my shooting this is good loot Oh an
arrow what a piece of [ __ ] has been
looted this has been looted there's
nothing in here let's go let's go let's
go okay I can't see well we don't looks
I haven't I can't reload [ __ ] dude I
don't even know how much ammo I have
stupid twitch o-o I hear something
that's a plane drop it's just an airboat
getting shot at yep let's go up go by
the trees go high trees he brought in
why they're shooting from that green
building what green building the big
building to your right right building
you're talking about okay just keep
running straight you're fine you're fine
right Mir no Stevie tonight sorry guys
he's got issues with tissues how do you
put the gun down so you can run faster
you probably hold why no it's not press
why hold why I hold why yeah you're
right okay here we go
alright now I'm running faster switch
camera oh it changes you from first to
third person yeah yeah yeah should I
don't think I don't know how much ammo I
have I hate that this is like Craig just
for you load your gun in your phone no
no no I only have nine bullets left
yeah this is like a track-and-field like
just this game should be called
cross-country racing I know at least 10
so much time Iran so cool I know it's
like violent cross-country racing it
just should be called what are you doing
on your screen Craig oh my god I mean
watch his stream I'm running why don't
you have your gun put away cuz I don't
trust anyone okay start shooting I want
to be ready wait start veering to the
right a little bit Pikachu you running
off the horse
we're headed towards that building let's
go to that building in front of us right
there okay our closes own we're good
we're not even in the [ __ ] zone yet
no my god the zones the island it's all
gonna hide be careful be careful get
your gun out back to us which guns how
you just gonna take [ __ ] that's what he
always does a psycho how man yeah oh
there's a grenade here there's a
telephone sorry I can't right now I well
though I'm going up I had to see what
there is
it's gonna blow my this is actually a
good building to be in great clothes did
I closed the door on myself understand I
just crazy
there's a motorcycle what hey what about
this other building up top here okay I'm
gonna go to this building up here flares
up here sounds like a fan somebody's
house
oh my god alright there's a building
down here in the zone I'm gonna found a
shotgun I found a shotgun okay good
who me to set this one down here when
you're done Griffin in the zone cuz
you're out of the zone Am I
oh yeah and the blue lines but where are
you guys oh I hear shots no I see you
guys alright I can't believe we're still
alive and we had this the only reason
why we're alive is because we went so
[ __ ] far on the map like we went yeah
well we're not in good shape we need
more [ __ ] they don't even have backpacks
I'm gonna check this house over here but
it's gonna be sketchy because there's
probably gonna be people around it yeah
or at least coming to it so just let me
know I don't mean my mic what are you do
what are you doing he's uh I don't know
he's got a fan of hoody are you making
it are you making a smoothie right now
like yeah okay okay okay Jesus man what
is it I know he won't tell you what he's
doing he just acts like ya
Justin no I know that's the annoying
part ya think you could just be like
well I have to fan on cuz it's hot my
brother but he doesn't do that he just
leaves it on acts like everything's
normal
alright this shit's been this [ __ ] oh I
finally found a bag this doesn't have a
[ __ ] backpack let's go to the town
wait hold on I'm getting ammo we got to
find a car man this is ridiculous we
should just find a car head to the
center and just wait hey there's a
backpack up here hey there's a backpack
up here see I'm coming away no it's
behind you
you guys already on the wrong house cuz
Pikachu's impatient when you talk my way
into the longhouse I'm at the house
behind you yeah yeah yeah I'm coming
oh it's too late it's on us it's on the
roof but you ran away already
I'm gonna go home Griffin see anything
in that grip is not openly yeah it's not
looted is nothing at all this is this is
a this is a [ __ ] ghost town this
place yeah chill here for a crank can
you go over
III about the games III was dope dude
cyber cyberpunk dude cyberpunk is the
[ __ ] I can't wait to play that and I
could she was way down here by himself
yep usual Pikachu doesn't husband team
play Podesta was like the winner of e3
dude by far Elder Scrolls at new what
what game elder there Elder Scrolls 6
they're gonna I mean it's way down the
road but they announced it and I have a
new star game and then fallout with
multiplayer is gonna be safe oh what a
loner game I know that makes much more
sense yeah all right these houses are
all rated [ __ ] the earth this is sketchy
we're in sketch evil yeah there's
nothing in here
Oh some ammo shot good joke well there's
a sickle way upstairs did you check
upstairs
what does the map look like Oh guys we
got to go and we have to cross the
bridge yeah we got to go to the town I
mean the military my god oh my god we
got to find a vehicle this is seven six
I need seven six two I'm all like
desperately do you guys see any um or we
just swim it oh that's true oh we could
swim oh that actually might be a good
idea you picked like a remote location
and swim across
yeah but be careful there's probably
people hiding around here um what else
was dope all pretty much all the Sony's
gameplay trailers are awesome last of us
to look really good
spider-man looks sick what was the other
one there's a couple other ones a new
Ori gameplay awesome
I say we swim right here yeah we're
gonna happen really we're gonna have to
go can you really swim the whole thing
yeah but now no you can swim but the
people on the bridge can snipe us or
people across the island but I don't
think we have a choice we gotta go
who's gonna take like five minutes of
swimming you hate running the wait till
you try swimming oh god there's a car
right here [ __ ] that where where well
come and get my work I bet it doesn't
work yeah see this white piece of [ __ ] I
know I mean I just I can't with him all
right here we go
this is gonna be fun well we could talk
about e3 while we're swimming so uh or
you already knew Ori and the blind
forest I look good you guys got to see
the trailer for cyberpunk 2077 if you
haven't watched it it's like a game I've
been doing this
does this blue thing come into the water
- yeah everything yeah that's why but
the work clothes we got to go to our
left that's the only problem it's like
right over the bridge this is not good
because there's probably people on the
bridge looking to shoot people then the
last one I'm saying I think we should
swim towards land I am but if we don't
get in the blue we're gonna get eaten by
the blue line you're saying I see what
you're saying well let's get on the
outskirts of it oh yeah start moving to
the right a little bit I see yeah yeah
we just got to get in the circle and
then we can kind of navigate around all
right
ridiculous we haven't done in front of
us I had the home run where we were
running don't happen I barely have scope
we're doing a [ __ ] triathlon I know
this stores why are we doing a triathlon
instead of play in the game don't so did
any of you see cyberpunk 2077 trailer
hey can you can you dive oh you can dive
- oh this is yeah if they start shooting
you can dive but they could still hit
you
I'll take a swim underwater I think that
line at the bottom you see a line at the
bottom that's gray others you should
ascend enough you're gonna drown how do
you but I can't I'm pressing ascend and
I don't know how to get up oh Jesus
like how do you get up just look up are
you aiming up I don't are you aiming up
a little bit all day okay I didn't have
my bearings dude relax okay there's a
boat underneath the bridge so let's try
to avoid it and one now we're in the
zone let's just stay okay we're Stan the
outskirts of the circle this is yeah
yeah yeah yeah right here this is
perfect just start headed towards I wish
you could get on those guys boats and I
mean you probably can and [ __ ] with them
but by the time we get close they're
gonna shoot you
they're right under that bridge so
ridiculous
so we're in the circle right now right
yeah okay coke city get on maybe around
now I haven't heard his voice yet though
um oh [ __ ] the circles closing alright
we did it
yeah are they shooting at us another
shooting this is actually brilliant I
think this little swim technique because
we're gonna get there and by the time we
get there look it's already 48 people
left I know but the thing is like
sometimes they sit on like the the beach
and they snipe you okay but we're kind
of going toward the outskirts so that is
good they're all know waiting bridge
going crazy though so I'm saying they're
too busy fighting on the bridge to not
even look at us over here yeah but
there's gonna be people at the military
base so where's the end on literally we
don't know the end all is right here
this is perfect
alright I'll put the market yeah we
should start all right let's start
swimming towards that well we're not
gonna be able to know those heights I'm
straight I'm saying I'm gonna go over
straight yet toward this like
little sand area it's easier to get up
yeah yeah yeah and then we can try to
wait is that a boat ahead of us probably
god this is a nightmare
yeah there was a boat to our right over
by the bridge but I don't know happen to
you guys should come where I am so we
can go under the bridge I don't want to
go into these kind of shouldn't get
close to the bridge that's where you're
gonna get murked yeah can you like you
be come with the team you guys are gonna
die how you the thing oh [ __ ] no matter
what we have to hurry up he's right
though because it's about to restrict in
one minute we're gonna die out here at
sea I'm coming just start swimming
towards the bridge all right I'm coming
well should get some faster I know this
is ridiculous it's the slowest thing
ever but in all I know this is not right
the most boring game restrict playing
through oh my god we're not gonna make
it
they were always I think it I mean I got
a couple you get this no no I think we
can get up here up right here like
straight where I'm going
yeah I think you can - this is this hill
yeah that area is fine I think you can
get up there we got it let's go let's go
all right you go ahead start running to
the circle just be careful because
there's gonna be people in there bridge
I'm not there yet
well I see someone I'll [ __ ] that blue
line that's coming in Locke that's what
I'm saying dude oh my god let me know if
I'm doing this right
why are you happy as Pikachu are you
near me there's a car oh I see somebody
running up the hill wait and you kind of
left the car right here I'm gonna grab
this car all right
you guys get that global going down
there already headed towards the car oh
there's a car right there
you see that car oh [ __ ] wait wait wait
take me get in [ __ ] yeah let him get in
cuz the the zones coming just go I'll
try to catch up or when they hit hit by
this blue line right now I'm gonna have
to oh they're coming behind you Dennis
they're coming behind you gotta switch
guns there we go I'm in love I'm in the
[ __ ] I'm in the [ __ ] red keep
going keep going oh I think I got him
okay keep going
oh there's another car [ __ ] we should
have got that other car I'm gonna have
to bandage in a minute oh [ __ ] Phil what
are you doing yeah you're right by the
zone what happened Oh as you could see
what's happening to drive up a hill like
a crazy person
yeah that sounds about right are you in
the zone at least I'm in the zone you
weren't his own
I think there's another car right there
oh well okay where are you headed
there's a new zone Oh oh [ __ ] okay we're
almost in it
yeah no I'm coming forty two people left
dude this is I don't know I'm running
outta ammo I know this is not gonna be
oh [ __ ] now don't worry I'm talking I
[ __ ] suck cuz he's gonna sting Oh
calm down
[ __ ] I had only a demo there's guy right
there by the trees watch out
I can't shoot Otis's oh just go to the
zone don't worry about me go zone people
do go to the zone look for ammo
this guy's gonna kill me I'll treat you
guys son of a [ __ ] yeah yeah all right
better anyway actually yeah to reach
retry this house Pikachu oh my god there
he goes I can't get in that house hold
on [ __ ] isn't he talking cuz he's got
that fan going that jerk-off fail close
this door good job okay alright I'm
going upstairs what what the [ __ ] have
you been doing you don't live in I had
to turn on the fan for my brother [ __ ]
how much ammo you guys got I don't know
D rounds dude we've just get in the car
where are we you guys are no stay where
you are you're in the zone stay there
stay there
hold up get your shotgun out that's what
you should be doing okay you're you're
seriously in like towards the center of
the circle close those doors you had
closed the other door peeks get that
shotgun ready cuz everybody's gonna be
coming to you look at where you are in
the zone you're real I only have five
shots left of this shotgun alright here
I can drop an m16 for you he's got an
m16 he just needs ammo okay wait
well they're getting close dude you guys
are so central it's ridiculous there
drop that in there's ammo cars coming
you watching that you have any bandages
Griffin no there yeah I got ammo
he cares pick something out look at this
dude he's got an ammo he's got extra
melons
oh there's more ammo on there Griffin
he dropped for you where behind him got
some bandages as well to your left to
your left to your left
let driven your left you know what are
you doing oh my god I have no idea load
your [ __ ] he was my I want I want this
gun oh my god they're these job now you
got two over sixteen who takes somebody
please take that shotgun because that's
gonna help you upstairs okay only five
shots in it piece of [ __ ] that's fine
two of them can kill somebody and
Griffin take those bandages hey did you
see those are baby angels good job thank
you
look where you guys are
dude look at the zone it's so bad oh you
can shot what the [ __ ] so just shot me
through the window through the window
when there's your bandages they're gonna
come in
Pikachu watch the stairwell yeah I see
the window don't peek [ __ ] door
closed hellos downstairs
I gotta go downstairs and close this
door okay I would walk there and bandage
I'll go bandage a bandage BAM okay how
do you bandage how to [ __ ] you get away
from the window first off you're back by
the window alright now go to your
inventory
there we go okay how did he do it go to
bandages the X or whatever I don't see
whatever I don't know how to do it so
Pikachu can you explain to make any
sense it doesn't make any sense
I don't know how to do it I can't I
can't I don't oh there we go
there you go Jesus Christ watch ah he's
coming in Griffin I was doing it banana
Steven this yeah if he's on but he
better be on right now come back okay
there you all right cool you know I
might a shop he could you that's what
banana said he said you did
yeah I know I started it starts I can't
ready up until there everybody's up rods
gonna start oh yeah
if there's gonna get a land oh yeah I
don't want to do that so hunter okay I
see here we go guys your friend
completely naked
yeah it's loading it how he's in oh here
we go ready all right okay let's do it
so yeah and okay go hopefully it'll be
better than destiny but it is third
person which I kind of like first-person
halo yeah but I mean like Halo gears are
so tired I mean and the fact that they
only showed like a trailer for Halo like
what the [ __ ] dude what was the last
Halo 365 300 Rd and right halo Guardian
or whatever that was but that nobody
really like it now play Halo no well
they have a new trailer for a new one
that's what they showed off at e3 yeah
I'm just over gears in halo truthfully
I'm burned down on that [ __ ] and then
it's really excited for soul calibur
cuzzo caliber but they didn't show much
of anything new at e3 e3 was really
disappointing this year to be honest
Bethesda had the best show by far that's
tearing I mean I love Kojima and it
looks cool I guarantee you that's a PS 5
release and I guarantee the reason PS 5
show was so weird is because they're
planning games for ps5 like they're
pregnant announce it next e3 guaranteed
the people are the same they had the dev
kits for ps5 so I think like I'm not
ready I'm not ready I'm not there I hope
well PS firearms out then maybe yeah
that means I don't want to compete ok
let's see which way we're doing what
extras came out last holiday I know no
[ __ ] another yeah no they're not making
another one alright we'll see should we
go Gatka let's go gecko
yeah kill marker all right let's do it
marker don't die
three three seven two jump one jump yeah
I mean I think they will do they're
gonna announce it next year and then it
won't come out till 2020 that's the
thing is that they're now just dirty
what's Griffin doing I'm following you
didn't anyone you gotta use your analog
stick in like you got push water there
you go
Oh push oh my god cuz I think we got one
there's one underneath me I don't go to
a backside of katka know there's once
more those we had a smaller town oh yeah
yeah Griffin is watch how there's a dude
like right next near you bro
what there's a guy landed right there
you so be careful he'll find it beat you
run I like to go and find it's not
rendered ever come on [ __ ] Raiders
already I can't close the door no it
won't let there we go my shit's not
rendering dude this is door okay there's
nothing in this house oh my god I wasted
my time I found a gun I found a guy
hello Griffin picks up the most random
stuff how come I can't switch to the gun
it won't switch did you press up cold
y-yeah
why are ya press Y up is for pistol y is
for guns oh and your military base again
you think yes back I got a I got a what
I get
where are you guys are you guys over
here near me yeah oh yeah
near you Lowell one vest well no it's
not me
oh you guys are here odo there you go
see I'm here I'm in the right place then
also what oh there's a level one
backpack right here I dropped it
no I got level two someone said do we
play battlefield I have but we haven't
recently they got some new great they
got some new level games on that now
well you know 5s coming out soon all
right I'm gonna try to head to this town
but I know there's a [ __ ] ton of people
that landed over here so well let's go
I'm right behind you what why don't you
tell me to come with you ah dude this is
what we think can you come with there's
a guy in front of you Craig there's a
guy in that building I know that's
enough Oh what are you doing dude
looking I know there's a low vision
terrible there was a guy in that
building right in front like right in
front of us right there yeah well we're
not gonna be able I can we get in this
camper can't get in the camper I will
we're [ __ ] cuz there's no guns around
here this guy's probably got some time
oh you guys going that far
oh my god Brent oh go get a shot where
did that come from
oh these right here Griffin
I'm coming what ahhh Craig's down it's
not over start over
nobody give me Griffin Griffin called me
get down here get over here Peaks take
about I'm coming no cable - I'm saying
Pikachu all right I'm gonna go with my
hunter I have a good player Todd that
was too funny that dude all he had was a
shotgun and he literally killed all
three of us that was amazing
that's definitely the opener it's
literally that was the worst thing I
really thought I saw I saw a Pikachu
rollin up with a big gun I'm like ah
here he goes dude he's gonna I had this
God be a hero that's all he had yeah
he'd killed ya
oh we have our handguns so like I tried
to shoot him but handguns are the worst
I tried to shoot him - I don't know what
was happening all right here we go sign
of them boulders well they don't have to
ask questions that they want to ask
questions they can not to push everyone
peeks
I know stop forcing it I know Jesus
Christ my dad's class ends uh uh let it
happen I was oh the meat oh the meeting
was great it was heated it was a heated
meeting
wait wait the meeting went so great that
four of our members aren't here today
[Laughter]
true that's all great to be anymore is
everyone ready to launch the upper
loadout ready yeah we're gonna die let's
go now our Instagram account only has
two people that work on it one of them
has to be Pikachu yeah unfortunately
wait wait let me change okay no mobility
I want to go larger
medallion popularity
oh let me do that I'm sorry I got one
trowels of the nine token okay I got
those oh yeah and once I'm the vanguard
this is gonna go great dude I can't
leave simple token there's a looming
boon of the vanguard should we pop pop
fireteam battalion already I don't have
any somebody's talking [ __ ] about
destiny yeah look dude we've been
playing destiny for five years we're not
gonna stop now I don't care how shitty
it is it's entitled kind of committed
with our destination we're gonna
definitely do some more pub pub guy next
time there's actually a update that
there is release later it's like winter
time yeah new map new key I know I
should optimize the game better yeah the
new map takes forever to load oh I will
say destiny don't get us wrong
somebody's asking the other day on
YouTube like aren't you guys burned out
yeah for most of it we are well we like
playing when we'd like to private
matches now and we'll do like tough
stuff like trials we got to get a raid
going that's our next big thing yes
we haven't tried the new raid we haven't
even tried the new rate I don't even
know what what to do with it
every time I say raid raid raid any guys
did it
I always say to do the raid that's my
thing that's my whole thing every single
[ __ ] time exactly well we need six
rave right now we have fours yeah but we
got to get Steve and coca-cola yeah well
I don't know I can only speak for one of
them as it was busy tonight and the
other one disappeared into the ether
went to the spirit world I don't know
where he was
20:29 is a hero chunk oh no that's right
oh it's this map and it's yeah we got
this dude let's count down this is I
already I already am not having fun who
its countdown is gonna be great what's
the scheme scout rifle
we're gonna get trashed this is gonna be
great
oh I should have got my positive outlook
you know what this team back she looks
steamed up spilling you know what maybe
because we're so bad they're teaming us
up with people are like like leveled
equally as horrible yeah oh that guy's
got Guardians a big ghetto huh oh that
guy oh it's gonna be under these three
so probably 30 more minutes okay
let's go let's go I saw rugs no rugs
yeah I say rugs
they're gonna come already this is a
night like you're not even bro down with
a little Peaks throw around the thing in
the middle there's one in rugs back
brush brush
well we're defendant [ __ ] how he's clear
Vice piece there they're planning up the
second location
mark okay how many are down to are down
those that's good too I kill - lets go I
got the heavy where are they they're in
this room I got that kid behind line
there you go
he's dead defuse defuse defuse defuse I
was defusing Pikachu or did you die nice
don't season me I'm not a piece of meat
to be seasoned
okay we starting off said that rugs
let's set out rugs Renison why here
that's all the nightmare what's the
difference
no but that other one least you have a
lot of space this [ __ ] is no space here
yeah but we can take them out
Oh some dude already killed himself that
said it I said it alright where Arthur
relax what are they they're heavies up
the car for heavy or have these up no
one's going to do I got it
where's that but where's that coming
from
Pikachu yeah ah under come here
Oh three coming in do you gotta talk
Pikachu
you can even whisper but we need that
know what's going on Griffin get him yes
good job Griffin oh the guys ready yeah
there you go yeah
brought it back here Mike even if you're
whispering okay hey you can't be live
look at 5.0 market they go to market go
to market go to market I think they're
gonna come rug this time oh my god we'll
go to market I'll meet you over there
I'm just gonna check it
I'll watch market hold on you watch my
Marcus clerk on the rail brush rugs
never [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up god damn it
please stupid they're all there they're
all there get that heavy vulgar you
should've got that heavy first watch ah
he's coming I know that damn it hunter
he's absolutely absolutely no just
Griffin look I can't get you up yeah
yeah well yeah but yep how you can know
they're pushing on you oh man I [ __ ]
that up sorry guys I ran into far I try
to throw up a shield and was slow about
it and so stupid
good job Pikachu sir
Oh sonica there we go
turn her back to push it in for the back
are you down oh [ __ ] holder put one of
them ran away I'm reviving I said it I
said it huh there's there's two out
there toward the left yeah get off me
you're pushing me
now here's my last dude oh yeah he's
running he's running
back in the middle alley just going to a
spawn point
good job be nice boys see we don't need
code dead last [ __ ]
one market and everyone run market yeah
one girl go mark you donk
you guys go to rugs I'll cover market
cuz I suck I'm sure they're coming
market dude be rugs they're going to
rugs yep yep they're gonna rugs are they
I'll see you Oh
got one
now fair-market I'm coming up behind
that market don't you they go to market
probably gotta go
that guy's hurt there we go
well where's this other dude he's there
right there
nice vulgar nice defusing shoot she
offered me protect bulghur protect
vulgar we got it we got it we got it
nice to third camping he shot his Goldie
I don't know yeah well I wouldn't the
same thing good for him
why don't we stop holding yeah but he
wasted it I mean yeah roads like we're
not gonna wind up just gonna waste my
super this route terrible idea
middle is layer a we back one pushing in
from the back
you try drop back he's running away
there's one still in the back porch I'm
dead there you go nice watch out Goldie
but yeah watch out he got drifted back
off oh [ __ ] back up back up back up he's
out he's out get him off the [ __ ]
thing
get pikachu up he's gonna guess guys up
Oh 35 it's alright no hold it off now
thank God
nah they got I got it sorry
they stopped supers [ __ ] I should've pop
I should have popped my Golden Gun
you're making me nervous talking to me
like that
sweet-talking hear ya [ __ ] plague
they've got it they've got a tether so
be careful but we got through it so I
gotta win these next two I'm hurt
they're all back there I'm right here
with you I'm dead one in the middle he's
hurt he's so hurt [ __ ] I can't believe
he did that
wait I'm coming for you he was absolute
dude I'm so absolute are using crimson
yeah I can't believe I'll [ __ ] off you
can kill him
where's he's hurt again he turned the
corner he's going back down go Craig
nice beat that boy
all right next one using supers steam
would be star here tonight coke I don't
know he disappeared off the face of
Miami
all right all the time don't use don't
use supers all at once but this is it so
we've got to use supers but they're
gonna anchor they have to anchors so
don't use it all at once yeah yeah
middles clear oh boy it was clear
there's my team when he was doing come
on you're you're arguing what behind you
I was right behind you they were all
there
hey I was right behind you be you're not
talking
wait are they did they load it up or is
it asked to load it's uh Stallone it's
awful oh it doesn't matter now we're all
waiting for you why were they bag last
one the team someone super when we got
to the I didn't have my super remember I
used it
why did use your super yeah oh so whose
fault is that you should have used it no
it wasn't the perfect girl all right
then they also didn't use either their
tethers so that's really not good guys
so I lose because they're on offensive
now whatever drugs yeah rugs will make
it where they won't God well it's up to
them anyway I build back a bottle since
we have tethers because it's easy to
defend it they're all three coming out
nice use your supers let's finish this
man yet all out there see the heavy hit
the heavy someone get too heavy
you got him you got him dad dad we long
got it good job boys
all right we got wow we're actually one
that's wind it's a waiver
Brad EPC used in the right time I can't
believe they didn't try to tether you
there but they didn't I'll Pikachu at
the top you did good you did good job
it's also because he's not talking he
does better when he doesn't talk
I know if you can't function ya know I
don't know what's going on you start
skinning and running at everybody Gamzee
could you Pikachu
rage shouts are you rage quit like a
couple like a week
now I was three days ago still ragequit
that's what sounds like little rays
world
let's horn anybody use the posse face
before gun concludes you a lot is that a
good out of rifle um I'll go rightful
for gun I don't know that one I've never
used that one
might be good never heard of that one
what are the stats like it looks pretty
good it's got like 7 20 per minute fifty
one magazine 720 that's good
but the real Meg mm-hmm let's just study
the stability it's okay use it yeah but
I like the Crimson though I just feel
like I can handle a lot oh yeah well you
get multiple shots also target yeah
we're whispering cuz Pikachu can't talk
his brothers probably like to sleep in
and Pikachu's bunk beds with his poor
planning no I don't have a bunk bed okay
oh oh now he wants to talk I know how he
times in about the only chimes in when
we talk about him otherwise you're just
I mean there's nothing wrong with a bunk
bed dude yes you know you're only 40
you're so little
20 20 minus a year junk time it's cool
dude thirty years old and a bunk bed
there could be worse things could be
he's not dirty
right right you're not 30 okay we don't
know it let's let's focus come on oh
look it that's how we're still doing the
introductions Remos right now I know
oh that's a nice helmet I just don't
know how to use a flashlight in his bunk
bed that's gotta be weird
what no it's not because you can connect
if you sleep at the bottom you can use
the springs from the markets clear
buckets Claire's rugs don't check the
middle there's one going to mark a t-rex
those were sweaty I got that guy one
down I got two I'm dead middle there's
potato I can't get you Boulder takes on
the middle you need to help Griffin I'm
dead [ __ ] sorry it was a 1v2
you don't cry you guys don't have to
whisper oh do I have to [ __ ] or not I'm
not was yelling I can't you know what's
yelling yeah just banana he's taking on
your personality oh my god they got
another okay
okay I'm just like dildo guard let's
don't stop rug stop yeah what's playing
with photos clearly we should just team
up oh shoot oh my god here well I got
that guy before I got revert behind you
Peaks there was a guy behind you to
justify us [ __ ] around
yeah there's so fast now these do but
should their [ __ ] thank you
how much do they got on all mobility oh
yeah yeah they're there realize yeah I
know their revives are sick dude their
revives are they're super on it let's go
let's go so I think we should stay in
the open market
let's go market yeah yeah that's pretty
we should go market too is it us to load
it no it's there yep there's two of them
market I'm dead three of them they're
all they're all fourth they're pushing
into the market right Pikachu you're in
swing up behind ah I need some more
teams like why they're looking for you
they're all hunters don't get us up get
us up get up too late right I know one
of those tiny kill picture you got it I
believe in you oh my god he's racist
let's let's pay market [ __ ] out some
[ __ ] [ __ ] rugs market and then we'll
play it will play heavy will play heavy
they're pushing fast so just go yeah I'm
the efficient super fast yeah that's a
that's always coke you guys that push me
see like these guys see what you're
doing approach [ __ ]
yeah one of them behind us behind us
behind us oh my god there was three of
them right here
like 2.5 killstreak yeah I got a Swami
dude yep at least I said it that's the
first time we actually said it this
whole game yeah look at the change yet I
don't have a I don't have a bunk bed
let's play drugs we're defending
marketing we're defending yeah so go
defend do what you're gonna do I'm gonna
go over here oh my god
Jesus yeah the team shooting also
[Music]
impairs a - you said Market Market yeah
no one else was with this I just don't
want you guys I was tired of it on a
dime oh my god oh my god let's go we're
going rugs and don't stop and watch her
left yeah okay you know what he says I
just use the weave the absolute worst
that's why I'm on the top I see what
you're saying
trying to help anybody
so yeah I'll help me shoot this guy
we're all dead we lost yeah what are you
talking about hey what are you doing I
was that's what had worked disk use you
pick people off when they're killing us
that's not what happened there that's
exactly what we do you know people could
see my [ __ ] stream they'll see that I
was [ __ ] [ __ ] and they'll see on your
stream that no one else is with you
that's true on the second round it's one
of those rounds I didn't want to go with
you guys oh oh I did cuz I thought okay
crank year well he's not a team player
he's just the worst with the most kills
it's just the worst try this I know that
let's just finish up the card still get
coins it's not the card we lost yeah who
gets the three times you get three
losses Oh about that how about that
bananas bad at math or I just forgot
haven't played it so long I know you
haven't been on a long acid I asked eat
you where you been it's been busy
I'll help the podcasting
this will Pikachu if you don't have a
bunk bed what would you call it a
side-by-side like a sleep horizontal on
it on a [ __ ] twin on a condom yeah
like oh my god here's one of those race
car beds actually think that Pikachu
loses brothers actually like normal size
right right
Oh that'd be so great any please buy
that Pikachu he has to jump in the bed
right into this slide it's got like a
little bit here it's got like a big
wheel like spinners yeah
oh please buy that Pikachu that'd be
amazing there's like lights on the
bottom can we start a fund raiser for
that I will talk to you later
sandbox track 2 fast 2 furious
that'd be like a bunion Pikachu eraser
all right focus team tree like he said
that's the reason why we didn't win this
last game I know I can come on bro come
on I know you do no worse than Griffin
rust
I know what does that supposed to me I
don't know peace yeah now he's back he's
a [ __ ] dog there was a specialty these
guys they're just me jumpin Uriel's gift
that guy's whales are staying a corner a
nameless midnight guy all right rugs
market all move together as a unit
yeah we're looking for rugs Jesus drunk
science bugs bugs hurt all right one
more have a rift up the back up Griffin
oh my god when he live does Muriel
Muriel he's dead me [ __ ] behind us
behind us behind us by the rift there's
one guy he's going to snap your tower oh
my god didn't kill her nature kill no
baracy you know what I mean play hella
game was that grenades like this Eddy
around them
I was trying don't stop I just don't get
it
good job Boulder he'd was lame thank you
all right let's go rugs let's attack
stop you get you what are you doing
ma'am oh just being Pikachu which means
he's starting to become idiotic that's
how it plays after he starts losing
gonna come there's some cheap shots
picture game shop he's ready hell yeah I
need help [ __ ]
it's another Garland watch out grenade
behind why are you guys all in the same
spot oh my god
and this is why I don't like rugs it's
my whole [ __ ] point
if you easily die in this [ __ ]
oh my god first I guess hey we got to
stick together we're together
no but this why don't like was because
this little room and one pulse grenade
can kill everybody all right yeah but
you guys wouldn't I mean you don't have
to be together in that room all right
doesn't matter let's go mark it [ __ ] it
I don't know what to say I'm done look
like we should have had those guys that
that was stupid
it's okay are you doing one all right
they're going rugs let's go yeah yeah
because they have all those grenades of
[ __ ] though yeah go to rugs to a bar
with them
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that guy come from all
right let's get heavy get heavy where do
you go got it I need help
ah he's up in that room up top there
somebody's got diffused I'm defusing oh
nice they're about to keel excuse
he's defusing dad I can't I die they
killed me
behind us [ __ ] sigh well we have
[ __ ] Charlie Chaplin on our team so
that doesn't [ __ ] help anybody
jeez what fries Oh Jeff the mute got the
girl from [ __ ] all that stupid water
monster movie where she's boning the
fish guy that's always middle rope shape
of water on our team where the hell are
you guys we're in the market I got
[ __ ] up yeah everybody's asking where
we are and we said we're gonna keep
going to market and then I'm dead
I got a picking market Pikachu can you
come grab me Griffin they're coming
towards you let's go oh [ __ ]
future I'm [ __ ] all three of them are
right there behind you Pikachu bot aah
he's going for the heavy it's a sign man
this was a bad start we said we're gonna
go market that we were going to market
altogether I know I was right Shanna
banana confused us man how is everybody
I don't know sorry I thought we said
Burke's no no no meat in milk
yeah come on we had a whole runs now I'm
one of rugs now cuz I feel they're gonna
come that way like they did last but I'm
watching they're like they're going up
the middle they go up the middle then
they split off yep nice nice good job
got two picks rugs back back room you
shoot them there we go I just take the
whole tea nice come on it's [ __ ] Wow
Pete you good job Peaks now mark in
Moscow it's our thing mark it let's go
watch time to learn little the right
part right here our left as well yeah so
why do they do that people always do
that she's like I don't know how to
throw you off they go down I don't get
it jumped foot too far
they'll beat you planet cover you I
can't I've been shot oh I'm getting
stuff all diamond oh come on
turn around get out get out get out oh
it's fine it's fine
I know bow saying like he popped at the
church there's no reason to run let's do
a Pikachu okay we gotta win come on yeah
come on
well you know they like rug so we should
go to rugs cuz that's what they like
middle
Pikachu Thunder boys yes go and fight
I think the corn market
oh that one's ties all this gets out our
clay our critter just rider in the
middle what there he's dead there we go
dummies there you go ran into my [ __ ]
the one you guys still have that sewers
and now I use mine to get that win
market let's go remember they have a
slam in a storm trance I'm gonna use my
golden gun up there over there and then
come over middle and cut across one down
oh they're coming middle the come in
middle there's two middle on the stairs
right there you could shoot to your left
behind you behind the time so I think
it's real I'll try to help you I can't
stop trying to help me oh my god
how come I didn't kill that guy no there
was no one there you know we should go
to rug so you could use your super rugs
and we have this plant it next time cuz
you'll be able to get yeah yeah you
clear it out yeah yeah throw good need
not over here they're going I think
they're going oh they're gonna mark it
now bradster planning running out from
behind oh Jesus Christ
they do something a nameless midnight to
make it good again it'll be fun coming
lamb and shotgun yep I'm dead you guys
we threw that we should have won this
movie you know what Pikachu where was
your super where were your guys is super
you guys never pop in you guys never pop
it we took mine yes yes nerdy IPOP yeah
Pikachu didn't pop it what I told him
every time he needs to pop it well
that's what he said to start that's the
plan right did tell you he did tell me
that Skype you he doesn't listen you
guys you you guys just always sit on
your supers like that's a that's a habit
I used to I used to it right in front of
you
eyelid so we got one more loss he's got
a long one loss and then we'll call it a
day see I knew we shouldn't talked about
flashlights cuz now Pikachu that's all
you can think about I'm Mike Craig you
jealous you want one
Oh Steve gave me enough first time yeah
when paid in mind a look like a
leprechaun no I mean oh sorry I go the
old-school route Disney Channel what's
up with Disney Channel you can't work
with them knew I wouldn't I think we're
out to Disney Channel it's not something
that it's old-school route do you wrap
it with newspapers yeah I use a
sheepskin joke oh man
so caliber so already I'm so ready I'm
so ready for so caliber that's my [ __ ]
shrunk good
I don't know okay five Bitcoin not doing
so up the troponins doing well right now
dude I know - I have stressed down like
so much money I know I kept telling I
kept telling everybody like don't invest
too much cuz I just don't trust it and
then of course but I don't doubt my my
initial investment though right
no exactly I know but it'll come back
okay clean pad just crypto in general
just you know they're all [ __ ] ya know
they'll come back because people will
see a need for it but to be fair it's
like it's definitely not even those
Studios would adapt it well I think I
think blockchain will become pretty
standard for a lot of different usages
not not just you know money but I still
think they'll be like three or four
currencies that kind of take hold
because I think they're gonna be people
who don't want to be part of the
marketplace the problem is they figure
out that it they're worthless I just
still don't know how they work I can't
solid explanation I mean the way they
work is that well at least in bitcoins
version there's only a certain market
cap and once that the market caps
reached it's not supposed to be any more
but then they kind of [ __ ] it up when
they did Bitcoin cash and some other
Bitcoin [ __ ] because like they split it
but the original Bitcoin is still just
there's only so many in a key and pretty
stat some point I think what the next
3-4 years it's done like whatever's out
is out but the bigger fact he said
the bigger problem is Justin says on
many that like there's different
versions but then we said is he needs
someone to explain it but you're just
making it more confusing for it
yeah thank you I mean he didn't explain
at all as to why even has value okay you
literally cuz there's a limited market
where there's a limited amount of the
coin in the digital world so what okay
but that's what I'm saying that's why
it's there and it's a camp it's not met
it's not managed by a bank it's not
managed by a third party it's just like
in in you know almost like it's in the
cloud and it's it's pretty and it's hard
to crack into because of how how the
yeah crypto works so that's why but it's
the same thing like why is anything
where water stocks were money there most
of that shit's [ __ ] too it doesn't
really matter anymore yeah but it
doesn't even matter okay okay okay
I'm market rotation Pikachu I don't care
rugs after people ask questions now he
wants us to be quiet I know I never
sorry let's play oh that's great you
push me thanks
they'll come in he's coming in he's
coming in I can't believe I didn't kill
that guy I was just at his head
understand this game sometimes do what
do you think the currency is for fun
feds Pikachu he's gonna get bunk poin go
check them out nice team shoot
I got two kills
what are you doing I know hold on I'm
dead oh my god I'm so confused - Griffin
was running back and forth with me I
didn't know who was who though we're
confused and put some smoke up Lowrey by
me I just can't be I'm your [ __ ] rug
market rugs
I'm not going mark it runs and I'm one
of them why do you want to go to a place
where it's a Death Zone
every time play smarter middle pikachu
middle go it's going to the heavy metal
who's got the heavy bottom Mina shower
like London right next to each other the
map is hard to tell like we literally
one good job guys
guys running like it's track meet or
some hey Kitty cops when Joe tell Kitty
thanks at least one of our friends likes
us Oh
up top though going up top get a boner
take that take that yeah there's one
more there's one more gripping up the
autumn pg5 thank you
- in the middle bark one going to the
back one going up the middle I got that
guy it'll bill damn it nice
okay ah vigilance is our last chance I
will mark it what do you want to do well
we could just be silent guys we don't
need to talk it's cool no it's like it's
like we died three times in a row middle
to rugs and then we die then you go well
you guys want to go now like die anyway
are you [ __ ] kidding me I know you're
crazy it's like when his way doesn't
work then he just goes okay what do you
guys want to do like what oh so close I
thought you really aimed for the wall
you got him and here comes craig lake
tinaroo go get a while there's a guy
right there there was nothing we were
gonna do anything it's no more corporate
crane she'd be camp out Craig no [ __ ]
off
camp out rugs are Mac market I'm fawn
Pikachu he's going rugs so I guess some
going rugs okay I'll call it out middle
to like a hero
backside one see him [ __ ] one came from
our spawn there we go - coming from our
spawn they swing them they swung around
watch how this guy's got arched rider he
could shoot - you're right he's in that
little upstairs always sniper area
that's not good look like oh we should
have had like to record that I needed to
record that because that was so stupid
I was like what were you doing Nicky how
was that playing terrible it was a
terrible grit was a terrible round
yeah no your mark and everyone would
mark a left oh maybe one because we
won't go to the far left he thinks being
on top of the leaderboard you know
Bernie Madoff was the top of the
leaderboard - it's clear that's what you
are behind us behind us behind behind
[Music]
the game guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]